the Orthodoxy these days on Galaxy
formation is that galaxies are built up
by mergers of little things so you start
with a bunch of little things they merge
together that blob merges with another
blob and pretty soon you've got a Galaxy
the problem is that you've got to do
that really really fast to explain
mature galaxies very early in the
history of the universe approach that
pebles and I took was very different and
that is a blob of gas collapsed in on
itself and started to form Stars it is
sort of fun to argue with the
conventional Orthodoxy because if you
start with things that are let's say a
million times the mass of the Sun and
you merge two of them you get something
that's 2 million times the mass of the
Sun and then you have to merge again and
get something that's 4 million times the
mass of the Sun and how the hell do you
get something that is pushing a billion
times the mass of the Sun in the time
that's allowed